on va organiser le plus gros direct qui
ait jamais eu lieu sur instagram dans ta
ville à marseille 12 heures de live tous
les jours
avec deux fans tirés au sort généreux
est vrai
[Musique]
gros ça c'est la chose à laquelle vous
partir le plus rond c'est le gant de
michael jackson qu'il avait lors de son
dernier show à vegas
c'est comprendre ma conscience à vous
avais jamais pensé pour le cuisiner
c'est super pratique un
[Musique]
gros creux
sur mu
nabil 30 ans nicolas 36 ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces deux gars qui vont bien chez moi
vous êtes tous faim dans la famille
n'ont pas bon pas bon en juin pas qui
vous êtes nicolas vous avez vu la maison
visiter la propriété j'ai visité la
maison met en cause de la propriété
on aurait pu avoir un conte sur deux ils
sont aussi convaincus c'est fou ça